this is brazil ricardo de gaba Bahia and
he's about to attempt to set a world
record for holding your breath
underwater do not try this at home but
before we find out how long that record
is let's see what he's up against
previous breath-holding attempts have
been made by people breathing in just
normal air before they start and the
record for this is 11 minutes and 35
seconds now Ricardo has taken this to a
whole nother level by breathing in pure
oxygen before he starts so how does
breathing pure oxygen help you to hold
your breath longer normal air contains
about 21% oxygen the other 79% is mainly
inert nitrogen now what Ricardo has done
by breathing in pure oxygen before
holding his breath he's flushed out most
of that nitrogen which means he ends up
with about five times as much oxygen in
his lungs that we would normally have
now that were an incredible 11 minutes
into the attempt what's happening to
Ricardo's body while he's holding his
breath premier is on simian notation and
moving to which toys and when Tiger a
dad of Kalia a sensation Mino Monta
generally in common my majestic attempt
pasa
Romeo severe contra Swanage a fragment
jahesh para the respiratory control
center of the brain is very sensitive to
changes in carbon dioxide in the blood
stream as the carbon dioxide builds up
in your tissues you feel this amazing
strong urge to breathe of course this is
our body saying hold on you're not meant
to be underwater holding your breath
please
get some more oxygen and the longer
wreath there the more that instinct is
building up so he needs to Train himself
and focus so that he can resist that
temptation simply to give up to his
brain and get out of the water
so pure oxygen and extreme training
combined to help Ricardo hold his breath
underwater for an astonishing 20 minutes
in 21 seconds
Thomas a sasame to boil super a song on
demise vs abacavir Lovano dome when
Adagio set I present an ami internal
image